نديم هل تاثرت العلامات التجاريه الداعمه
لاسرائيل بعد المقاطعه باختصار تاثرت هذا
نوع من انواع الضغط للقوى
الناعمه للقاعده الاستهلاكيه اذا جاز
التعبير وهو في عننا اتجاهين الاتجاه
الاول زي ما شفنا في قطاع المشروبات
والماكولات حاليا تراجع في الاسهم بلا شك
سينعكس على حجم المبيعات والنتائج الاعمال
في الربع الرابع لهذا العام الاتجاه
الثاني هو انعكاس للاتجاه الاول مدى قوه
هذه الحمله ومدى استمراريتها كل كانت اقوى
كل ما كانت مستمره كل ما كانت نتائجها
اكبر على هذه الشركات بحيث انها تعيد
التفكير بربط نشاطاتها
بالامور السياسيه وايضا هي عباره عن مثال
حي للشركات الاخرى انه ترى كيفيه رد الفعل
مهما كان حجم يعني مثلا في العالم العربي
حجم السوق بالنسبه للشركات العالميه حجم
سوقنا مش كثير كبير ولكن عم بثر عم نسمع
في اصوات مسانده لهذه الاصوات في منطقتنا
العربيه اثرت على مبيعاتهم في تلك المناطق
والامثله كثيره على شركات تراجعت عن عقود
رعايه فيما يتعلق اذا ما تحدثنا عن
اسرائيل فيما يتعلق بخوادم
الحوسبه شركات تراجعت عن بيانات السكان
ايضا هناك شركات تراجعت عن رعايه بعض
الانديه الاسرائيليه نتيجه هذه الضغوط فلا
تستهين في
مشاركات الاشخاص في حملات المقاطعه